[Musique]
bonjour
tu veux bien qu'on discute un peu
dans la maison tout de suite ils étaient
quatre qu'est-ce qu'on a dit tu ne dois
pas dire de mensonges quand on parle
s'il vous plaît
je suis là n'est pas peur
on ne pouvait pas de mal mais vous devez
rester ici dans la maison avec nous
depuis toujours des familles sont
choisies pour prendre cette décision
votre famille a pour mission d'accepter
de sacrifier l'un de vous trois pour
empêcher l'Apocalypse on y va sacrifier
personne chacun de vos refus des
centaines de milliers de personnes vont
mourir
ça y est ça arrive vraiment ma chérie
ferme les yeux
êtes-vous prêt à faire un choix il faut
que vous arriviez à nous faire confiance
on est des gens normaux comme vous peu
importe ne croise que vous dites
nous ne choisirons personne
[Musique]
désolé mais la règle c'est que personne
n'a le droit de partir donc vous n'aurez
pas choisi
tu crois vraiment que c'est une
coïncidence je suis obligé d'y croire
mon fils va mourir il s'appelle Charlie
en tant que mère je vous en supplie vous
seul pouvez arrêter ça
embauche j'ai vu quelque chose dans la
lumière tout à
la jure sans la
je vais partir avec ma famille
si vous ne faites pas ce choix ce sera
la fin du monde
on nous accorde une chance de décider du
sort du monde entier la planète est au
sourcils j'ai peur
rien n'est aussi imparfait et parfait en
ce monde que notre famille je vous en
supplie faites un choix
je vous le demande une dernière fois
vous devez choisir
[Musique]